I am Laura Ingram this is Ingram angle
from a very busy Washington tonight
falling stars
that's the focus of tonight's angle
now how many times has the regime media
told us that some emerging Democrat is
going to be the next big thing the next
big star
now on rare occasion as in 2004 when
Obama spoke at the DNC the build-up paid
off
but that happens maybe once in a
generation
back in 2020 they desperately wanted
Kamala to be the next Obama she was a
former prosecutor tough no-nonsense a
woman of color
your City Council made that decision the
federal government must step in that's
why we have the Voting Rights Act and
the Civil Rights Act that's why we need
to pass the equality act that's why we
need to pass the era because there are
moments in history where States fail to
preserve the civil rights of other
people well we all know where that all
ended up
but we need to do domestically what we
need to do to bring down the cost of gas
well right
right I seen a meme the other day that
said me Googling online how to make gas
at home okay oh don't do that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that was hilarious now the Border may be
open Ukraine might be a mess but she
still has that cackle
bad for America but this is what happens
when firsts and diversity are given more
weight than talent and Merit
the Press doesn't care right they they
think they're smarter than Joe Q public
and when they say someone's a star that
someone should win period
Stacy Abrams is a rock star we already
know that she is a rising star in the
party despite having lost that election
she's a very charismatic politician you
have Stacy Abrams who I would argue is
not a rising star of the party but
already established as a leader of the
party
oh really well how's that all worked out
Governor Brian Kemp is going to beat her
handily he's up almost six percent in
the RCP average in Georgia and has all
the momentum
who can forget that former punk rocker
turned political Boy Wonder from Texas
Texas Democrats call it Beto Mania and
in the last days of this U.S Senate
campaign Beto O'Rourke appearances are
designed to generate rock star style
pandemonium battle though has been a
rock star ever since he ran in Texas and
there's so many comparisons to Obama he
is a rock star among Democratic politics
he's a national figure he can
nationalize this race
it's such original commentary isn't it
apparently losing to Ted Cruz is not a
sign he'll have better luck running for
governor because Governor Greg Abbott
leads him by 8.5 percent in the RCP
average
let's skip over to Virginia though shall
we we're Abigail spanberger was running
in Virginia's seventh congressional
district back in 2018 and then the party
sold her as a moderate Democrat a lot of
conservatives there right in that
District well of course reporters they
went right along with the charade
The District in Suburban Richmond has
not been held by a Democrat for almost
50 years spanberger will also be the
first woman ever to represent the
district you said Democrats shouldn't
appear to be two partisan it doesn't
always have to be in US versus them we
need to stand up for it as opposed to a
left versus right or Republicans versus
Democrats it should be in American
values that we all stand up for
she says nothing and means nothing the
truth is spanberger is just another
Nancy Pelosi liberal voting with the
speaker 100 of the time
and we know how that's all worked out
for Virginia families don't we
enter yesley Vega and America First
conservative now this race is close but
the momentum is with the Republican
no wonder Politico is freaking out the
reporting that Democrats are sweating it
they thought they had elected a bright
political future in 2018 but now their
bench of potential Statewide leaders
could get wiped out in the midterms
one such Supernova was this woman
Michigan congresswoman Alyssa slotkin
you were very public about that you will
not support Nancy Pelosi does anything
in that change post Tuesday
no I mean I've been really clear for a
long time now I never want to be
disrespectful to anyone who served
especially a woman who broke glass
ceilings but we need to hear what people
are telling us on the ground and that's
they want a new generation that thinks
differently and works harder and just
takes the caucus in a New Direction
do you think she knows how funny she is
the truth is slotkin is the furthest
thing from an independent thinker voting
with Pelosi 98 of the time
I think what matters is how are you
helping people's pocketbooks or their
kids and if you can't speak to that as a
candidate you don't deserve their vote
period
oh that was so nice of course everything
she voted for has led to more pain and
suffering for Americans by our own
metrics slotkin should lose her job
and speaking of the Democrats once
touted as the new face of the party
congresswoman Katie Porter was near top
of the list
Katie Porter who is another freshman
member of Congress in what is already
the brightest group of freshman house
members that I've ever seen a rising
star in the Democratic party
congresswoman Katie Porter
well her profile Rose all right but
not in the way she wanted
Tech's exclusively obtained by Fox News
showed Porter berating Irvine mayor
Farrakhan and trashing the police for
their conduct at one of her Town Halls
last year
the man she lived with was arrested
after he allegedly punched a pro-trump
protester giving the protester a bloody
nose so she was upset that he was
arrested now the fact is Orange County
made a huge mistake in 2018 by electing
her she doesn't represent their values
at all she's Gavin Newsom and kind of a
curly black wig no one takes her
seriously
especially since when she dressed up
like a superhero on the house floor for
Halloween everyone just left but not
with her at her zero judgment that girl
would never have voted the way Katie did
let's talk about what's in that package
of course there's the climate part which
is
you know it's been hot lately it's life
or death it's life or death I mean if we
don't do something
Orange County is going to feel like Las
Vegas and that would be the end of the
world for people in Orange County we're
soft people
well soft people maybe I'll go with that
one
um she's likely to lose to Republican
Scott bow
good riddance
so the real question is with all these
falling stars if the Democrats get
shellac shellacked and their stars do
fall to the firmament well they learn
anything from this
how about the media was it smart for
them to nominate a guy who can never
seem to find his way off a stage
including today in Pennsylvania
[Music]
it was kind of a ballerina move
Biden was too weak to resist the crazies
on the left and now that whole act has
destroyed his presidency and much of the
United States economy nice work kids
the voters don't care about who either
party anoints as their next big star
they care about whether they have enough
money in the pockets to pay the bills
and whether the streets are safe to walk
on
the Democrats have delivered on none of
this they're all shooting stars
so when you see one make a wish before
it disappears
just like the Democrat majority and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else